you know anything about America you know
Ford's f-150 the famed pickup truck has
been in production since 1948 and it's
usually used for schlepping around
construction materials or to give
American drivers of certain machismo you
don't really get in a fiesta but if you
thought the civilian version was a bit
much
wait until you need the Raptor like the
new f-150 this monster is made from
aluminum making it 500 pounds lighter
than the outgoing version between
turbocharged three and a half liter v6
handily beats the old v8 in horsepower
and torque four-wheel drive new racing
shocks and an extra dose of america send
the canyon arrow up raptor not just off
the road put into the air so america if
you've got a grudge against the
wilderness it's time to get